[MUSIC PLAYING]
ASHUTOSH TRIPATHI: Welcome
to day three of Google Next.
Thank you for attending this
session about Modernizing
and Migrating to Cloud.
My name is Ashutosh Tripathi,
and I am the cloud customer
engineer with Google Cloud.
Co-speaking with me today is
John Sherwood and Jonathan
Lee from CBS Interactive.
I will let them introduce
as they come on the stage.
I'll quickly catch
up on why part
of the cloud, why enterprises
are migrating to the cloud.
Can I get a quick show
of hands, how many of you
own your own power grid
to supply electricity
to your houses?
As expected, I
got only one hand.
But as we know, owning
our own infrastructure
is not really a cost-efficient
way to supply electricity
to our houses.
Similarly, enterprises
are realizing
that owning and operating
their own data center
is not really cost-efficient.
Real differentiator comes, what
kind of products and services
we deliver to our end customers.
That being said, there are
top four migration drivers
for the enterprises of any
size to migrate to the cloud.
The top one being the growth.
Lot of organizations are
looking to release new products
and services to serve
their end customers.
They want the tools
and capabilities
to react to the changing
market conditions.
And with the technology,
you can serve your customer
across the globe, whether they
are sitting in Africa, Asia,
or right here in North America.
And the risk mitigation.
Risk is not only about how do we
prevent attacks to our system,
but also meeting the
regulatory compliance,
whether it is around
data residency,
or having a secured platform
to serve our customers,
and build a reliable
infrastructure to serve
our applications
to end customers
in case of any natural
disaster or calamity.
And as you heard,
Google Cloud has
regions across the
globe, that way you
can bring your applications
and services closer to your end
customers and have a reliable
and fault-tolerant architecture
for your applications.
Innovation is one
of the key drivers.
Customers are looking to
move to the cloud the way
that all these technologies,
whether it's around
artificial intelligence, machine
learning, big data, the cloud
provides.
It is not only
helping enterprises
to explore new frontier
to serve their customers,
but also differentiate
from their competition
and build a reputation as
forward-looking organizations.
While doing all
this, cost is also
one of the most
important factor.
Cloud provides various
productivity tools,
to automations
capabilities, and also
let you have the infrastructure
based on your varying demands,
whether it's peak or off-peak,
you can set accordingly,
and choose the financial
model that works
best for the organizations.
Now, cloud is not only about
innovation and disruptions.
It's also about how
organizations are transforming.
They are evolving
to have applications
of the environment
which can serve
the whole ecosystem, their
customers, their employees,
their partners.
And there are
typically four stages.
First is the divest.
As I mentioned, owning and
operating your infrastructure
is not the key differentiator
for most of the organization.
Make it someone else's problem.
Make it Google's problem
to run your infrastructure
efficiently, securely,
and reliably,
all that at a lower cost.
Invest in the areas which
help you differentiate,
whether it is around artificial
intelligence or machine
learning.
And Google has been doing
it for many, many years.
Let us help you
make you successful.
Empower your developers with
the tools and the capabilities
and the platform
so they can build
the exciting applications to
drive the customer engagement.
Help your employees be more
invested with the business
and grow your partners.
And all this transformation
comes around three things--
the right culture,
the right technology,
and right processes.
Even the large
organizations are realizing
that size is advantage
to them, and they
are looking to transform
how they do business
and how they serve
their customers.
At a very high level, the
infrastructure modernization
can be said, how do we
have a secured performance
and reliable architecture and
a platform at a lower cost?
It could all start
with the compute, which
is the first journey to
many of the organizations,
whether you are looking to
build new applications using
serverless
technologies, or you're
looking to migrate your
applications to the cloud,
whether for disaster
recovery or hosting
any of your custom applications,
such as SAP and others.
The storage.
Many of the organizations,
whether they
are in the media and
entertainment space,
or in health care, financial
services, and many other,
they have a lot of data
sitting on the [? tape. ?]
At Google, we provide
the different type
of storage, which works best
based on the type of media
you are looking to move,
or content you are looking
to move to the cloud.
Network.
You heard Sundar saying
that we have laid out
the fabric under
Pacific and looking
to do under Atlantic, as well.
Network is the key
no matter what we do,
whether we are connecting
on-prem to cloud
or having a hybrid architecture,
or also providing services
to our customer.
Or we are doing some
specialized tools
around AI/ML and everything.
So it's all about highly
scalable, highly reliable data
center, or the
capabilities in the cloud,
what Google Cloud
provides actually.
So just quickly,
the quick question
that comes to everybody's
mind here, how do I start?
So it starts with how do you
assess your applications,
what type of applications
you have in the portfolio,
and what they are doing.
And other thing comes about
planning your application,
planning your move,
the dependency.
There are some applications
which may be cloud-ready,
but there are some which may
not be even ready for the cloud.
So plan your order
and pick your part,
whether it is migrating
or lifting and shifting
or re-architecting
your applications.
And while doing this, how do
you optimize your applications
and operations and have
a constant feedback
loop to get to started
and optimize your journey?
We have a large number of
customers who are modernizing
and migrating to GCP.
And it's my privilege to
invite John Sherwood, VP
of engineering from
CBS Interactive,
to share his journey.
John.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN SHERWOOD: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
Oh, clicker.
Hold on a second.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- When we started
CNET in 1995, it
was all about helping
thousands of people
get the most from
their computer.
- Here at CNET,
we've been testing
Windows 95 for some time.
It's new.
It's different.
- Then came the internet.
- You've got mail.
- HDTV and the smartphone.
- Today, Apple is going
to reinvent the phone.
- The world had
officially gone digital.
Since then, CNET has helped
hundreds of millions of people
master a connected life.
- Do-it-yourself tech.
- Hey, Siri, close the shades.
- OK, let's actually
start with what we do now.
- Let's check out
what it can do.
- How to kid-proof your
streaming services.
- When there's massive
change, market confusion,
and untapped
opportunity, you'll find
CNET making tech make sense.
[END PLAYBACK]
JOHN SHERWOOD: All right.
Hi, everyone.
I'm John Sherwood,
Vice President
of Engineering and Technology
for the CNET Media Group,
part of CBS Interactive.
We're going to talk
today about our journey
to GCP, which we
completed last year.
I'm going to talk briefly about
our migration at a high level,
and then Jonathan Lee,
director of Dev Ops,
is going to come up.
He's going to go
into some details,
and then take you through
a demo of a system
that the team built to replay
our traffic before we actually
sent production
traffic into GCP.
First off, a little bit
of history about CNET.
We were actually founded
in 1994 as a television--
we were producing television
shows about technology.
Quickly pivoted
to the web in '95.
In 2000, CNET acquired
ZDNet to form CNET Networks.
I am proud to say
that I actually
wrote the code for that
page there on the right.
I know what you're thinking.
Yes, Ziff Davis
did hire children
to write code back then.
So CBS Interactive was--
CBS bought CNET Networks in
2008 to form CBS Interactive.
CBS Interactive is a
collection of all the brands
you see there.
And there is actually
a lot more that I
couldn't fit on the slide.
With more than 350 million
visitors each month
to our properties, we
are the 14th largest
property in the world, and
we're the 7th largest in the US.
Just to give you
some perspective,
the top five include the likes
of Microsoft, Amazon, Google--
I should've said Google first--
Facebook.
So we're in good company there.
CNET Media Group, that my
team is responsible for,
is the majority of
the non-CBS brands.
And we decided to
start our journey
with CNET, which is
actually the largest
brand of that portfolio,
mainly because it
had a relatively modern stack
that we were working with.
We had gone through
a modernization
a few years before.
I put this up here.
It's kind of an eye chart.
I just want to kind
of show you when
we said we were going
move CNET into GCP,
this is what we were dealing
with in the beginning.
But basically, it's a PHP web
app fronted by a CDN proxy.
Behind that is a varnish.
And then we have APIs.
Behind that is Mongo,
Solr, MySQL, and then
we have Java
applications that are
doing the processing
for big data,
bringing in our product catalog
and pricing information.
So while our journey actually
started a little less
than two years ago,
CBS Interactive
has actually been in the cloud
for probably more than a decade
with some of its properties.
So there has been
some experience there
and not all of it's been good.
A few brands went
in several years
ago only to be pulled
out pretty quickly
once we got the sticker shock
of how expensive it was to run.
But that tipping point
passed a few years ago,
and now it's much more cost
effective and efficient for us
to run in the cloud.
I'll move on.
So just quickly getting
in here, of course,
there's the operational
efficiencies.
We can spin up
servers and hardware
within a matter of minutes.
We don't have to go through
long procurement processes
that we used to
have to go through.
Of course, we would
always over-provision,
so we could handle
our peak load,
but then we'd have a bunch
of hardware sitting around
that we weren't using.
And we had to do a whole
lot of guessing upfront,
what we were going to need.
So now we can quickly spin
up what we need at the time
that we need it.
We can get prototypes
going really quickly.
And then, of course, there's
the cost efficiencies
and transparency.
So we can actually see and
pay for what we're using.
Before we used to
have this model where
we would pay for the
cost of the data center
and the teams that managed
that by the number of servers
we had running in
the data center.
So what happened was, at
the end of every year,
when they did that
allocation, there
was a mad scramble for everyone
to shut down as many servers
as we could, so we wouldn't
be left holding the bag.
As soon as that
process was done,
everyone would start
up servers again
and it'd be the Wild West.
Of course, we want to be able
to leverage managed services.
We don't want to be--
as Ashutosh said, we
don't want to be doing
all of the core infrastructure.
We want to be solving business
problems core to our business,
even though we've been
around for a while.
And so we had a
history of having
to build things ourselves,
like CI/CD and Search.
We actually developed
Solr and released that.
But now we don't
have to do that,
and we don't really
want to be doing that.
Security, of course.
For a long time, there was
this mantra of, oh, the cloud
is not secure.
That's not actually
the case, it's
just you have to think
about it in a different way.
You can't just draw a nice
ring around your data center.
You actually have to
think about the components
and how you're going
to secure them.
We could leverage
Google's network.
Their global network can get
really close to our customers
much faster.
And we also leveraged
direct connect from our data
center into GCP.
And that was really important
for us as we did our migration.
And then, of course, high
availability disaster recovery.
We were running in a single
data center in Phoenix.
So, of course, there's
problems with that.
If something happened to a core
networking router or something
like that, it could take down
everything and take us a while
to recover from that.
Google, we can spin things up
in multiple zones and regions.
I will admit, when
we first launched,
we actually went out in
one region, one zone.
We did like for like,
and that was really just
to keep the scope of
what we were trying
to do as small as possible.
But soon after we launched,
we went multi-zone,
and that was relatively
quick and painless
for the people who
actually did the work.
So how do we do it?
I'll bring Ashutosh's
slide back up here.
And we basically went
through this process.
We assessed what
our applications
were doing, what our systems
and infrastructure were.
We planned what we could do--
what we could move and
when we could move it,
and looked at all the
dependencies and complexity.
But we didn't want
to wait too long.
We wanted to get migrating
because GCP was new to us,
and we knew that there was a lot
that we probably wouldn't know
and we were going to have
to learn along the way.
And then, of course,
we optimized.
Like I said, we went
multi-zone afterwards.
So we went to set off to figure
out what we were going to do,
how we wanted to do
it for each system.
We came up with a design
plan for each one.
Could we leverage
managed services?
If not, did we have
the expertise in-house
to set up those systems
and maintain them?
For example, we
didn't really want
to set up and maintain
our own Hadoop clusters,
so we decided to leverage
Dataproc as a managed service.
But some of those
decisions required, then,
some refactoring and had impact.
We knew we could
containerize, run in VMs,
so some of the things
we wanted to do
was pretty straightforward.
And then, once we had a
rough idea of the design,
we would compare that with
a straight lift-and-shift
to see if just doing a
straight lift-and-shift
was actually more
cost effective.
But I will say, we were kind of
morally opposed to doing just
straight lift-and-shifts.
We wanted to gain some wins
out of moving into the cloud
and not end up with
the same thing,
just in a different location.
While we were doing that,
a broader steering group
was solving these problems
across CBS Interactive.
And these were things
that I didn't want my team
to have to be responsible for.
And quite frankly, they
needed to be solved
across the entire company.
How are we going to manage
users and their access?
What was the networking
going to look like?
How are we going to
connect to the data center?
How was the network
going to be managed?
Security, what
were the policies?
What were those going
to be and how were they
going to be enforced?
And then, of course, billing.
How were we going to
divide up the costs
to make sure that we did get
the transparency that we really
wanted?
At a high level, this is
what our project looked like.
So as I said, we started with
a design and architecture
and did that for a
couple of months.
And then, we decided, as I said,
some of our back end systems
were much more complex and were
going to require more thought
and refactoring,
so they were going
to take a little bit longer.
We knew that our front end
stack was a little bit simpler
and we could get that
out more quickly.
So we decided to break the
project up into two phases.
And also, I'm kind
of impatient and I
didn't want us to have to
wait until everything was done
before we started
learning, so that's
why we went with two phases.
The first phase was really
all our front end reads,
and that allowed traffic to
come in to those systems.
The writes stayed in our
legacy infrastructure.
This also gave us the ability
to slowly ramp up traffic
into the cloud,
so we didn't have
to flip a switch, which
was very important to us.
So this is what the phase
one architecture looked like.
You can see there, on
the right, our writes
were going into our
legacy data center.
And then our legacy web apps
were still serving traffic
there from those data sources.
We were replicating those
data sources over into GCP
through that direct connect.
And then we had our
containerized applications
sitting in GCP.
And then we used
our CDN as a proxy
to slowly ramp traffic
up over to GCP.
Over the course of a
few weeks, we did that.
And then we had 100% of
our traffic running in GCP.
I'll put an asterisk there.
It was almost all of our
traffic, all the reads.
So then we were able to--
when all of our back end
systems were ready to go,
then we already had
most of the traffic
over there, so actually the
launch went really smoothly.
We were able to break
replication, turn
on those new write services to
point at those replicas that
were now the masters.
And this is what
we ended up with.
Doesn't this look way
better than that first
graphic I showed you guys?
And then coming back to this,
this is actually phase 0.5,
so this is our
infrastructure setup
before we started
proxying traffic over.
We wanted a way to
load test and do
functional testing
of that system,
so the team developed
a replay system
that could take our traffic
using Stackdriver, Cloud
Pub/Sub, and Cloud
Functions to replay
our traffic in real-time.
Allowed us to dial
that up and down
and we were able to
actually, I think,
run 300% of our traffic
over into the new system.
So it really gave us a way
to fine-tune and configure
our new system before
any real users actually
had to experience it.
And Jonathan Lee is going
to come up and give you
a demo of that.
So, of course, this was a huge
effort, and most importantly,
a huge team effort
and a ton of details
that I haven't even gotten
into, and Jonathan will start
to get into some of those.
It required a ton of focus,
collaboration across my team,
across CBS Interactive,
with Google.
We also had some partners
that we worked with.
Deloitte provided some
contractors for us.
And I'd like to say
thank you to them.
Many of them are in the
room today, so thank you.
One of which, who is a star
student sitting in the front
here, is Jonathan Lee.
He's director of Dev Ops
for the CNET Media Group.
I'd like to bring
him up and take you
through some of the details.
JONATHAN LEE: This is one
of the critical systems that
makes CNET CNET.
This is our catalog
back end system.
So just wanted to call it
out along with pricing, which
is a similar system,
but both systems
take advantage of a lot
of managed services.
So they're taking advantage
of BigQuery, Dataproc, App
Engine for Cron, preemptible
VMs, Pub/Sub, and then
Cloud Storage.
And then building on top of
that, for our testing strategy,
this is a front end proxy.
So this is where all of the user
traffic came in from our users.
It came in through Akamai, where
we did that traffic splitting
that John covered.
It hit the Google load
balancers that then proxied over
to Varnish instances.
The Varnish instances
did not support HTTPS,
so we had to use--
leverage another open
source product called Hitch.
And what Hitch does is it
just terminates the HTTPS
and tucks the
Varnish over the box.
And then from there, we can
talk to the internal Swarm load
balancers and then
off to container
LAN for our front end.
So I want to talk a little
bit about the infrastructure
tooling.
So one of the things we wanted
to do during our migration
to the cloud is to
adopt infrastructure
as a code that allowed
us to do more automation.
So we leveraged Jenkins
and HashiCorp products.
So Jenkins would talk
to Packer and Terraform
and provision our
compute instances.
And then Terraform
would actually
provision out those Packer
images to our infrastructure.
So we managed to standardize
on Ubuntu as our base image.
We had three flavors, 1404
for our legacy applications,
1604 was what we tried to
adopt for most of our newer
applications and all of
our Docker Swarm stuff.
And then we started leveraging
1804 as it got released.
So jumping back to the security
that John mentioned earlier,
we leveraged a lot of security
in our infrastructure.
We had Tenable, which
basically just told us
when we needed to patch the OS.
We had Signal Science.
That's basically
set in our Nginx
and was the WAF for
our applications.
We had Aqua Sec that did the
container image scanning.
Vault, which kept
all of our secrets.
And then we also, which is not
on here, Cigital and Checkmarx,
which also did static
analysis of the code.
So what does the security
integration look like?
So tying in all
those security tools,
we had Tenable
that would actually
be baked into the Packer without
registering any of the images.
That got pushed up
to cloud storage.
Terraform would actually
push out those Packer images,
then registering those VMs as
they were spun up with Tenable.
Then we had Signal Science
running on the compute engines
inside the Nginx.
And then, obviously,
Vault could be
used for shipping any sort
of secrets over to the VMs.
For containers, building
on top of the last slide,
we also leveraged Jenkins to
push to our own private Docker
registry, which we just ran the
open source Docker registry.
We're in the process
of moving over to GCR,
so that's another
managed service we're
going to take advantage of.
We use Nexus to manage
any sort of artifacts.
And then as Jenkins was pushing
out those containers to Swarm
during that build
process, we would
leverage Aqua Sec to do
the image scanning to make
sure they were in compliance.
And then we also ran
Aqua Sec enforcer inside
of the Swarm clusters,
which could tell us
if any of the containers
were out of policy.
So as for Docker services, most
of our stateless applications
were Dockerized.
And we had a pretty
standard setup
where we tried to follow
best practices, which
is one process per container.
So we had containers
that ran the Nginx,
and then those actually talked
internally in the Swarm cluster
over to PHP, Python, whatever
other application languages
we were running.
So now I want to get into
three of the things that
are most critical for
any cloud migration,
and this should be useful
for just about everyone.
So the first one is logging.
You have to have logging to be
able to migrate to the cloud
successfully.
So before we started
our GCP migration,
we decided to integrate a
lot of our tooling into GCP
before actually moving
the applications over.
So we needed to get those logs
from the on-prem data center
into GCP.
So we tried to leverage
all of the tooling that
was on the machines without
actually editing any of them
or adding any new software
or anything like that.
So for Solr, for
instance, we had
our syslog running on the VMs
inside of our data center.
We just had those remotely
ship those logs over
to Fluentd boxes that
were running in GCP.
Those Fluentd boxes basically
just proxied those over
and authorized them
with the GCP platform
and then shipped those over
to Stackdriver Logging.
And then, for
containerized workload,
we leveraged another open source
logging driver called logspout.
And that effectively
did the same thing
that our syslogs did, which
is ship the logs over to GCP.
So once they got into GCP,
got into Stackdriver Logging,
we now had visibility across
our on-prem data center
using GCP's Stackdriver Logging.
So from there, we
decided that, well, we
need to get people
on board with GCP.
A lot of people haven't
been trained on that,
so we decided to leverage
another architecture.
How many people know
about the ELK Stack?
So for the people that
don't know what that is,
that's a Elasticsearch,
Logstash, and Kibana.
Logstash actually parses
the logs, ships them
to Elasticsearch,
which stores them,
and then Kibana's
like a pretty GUI
that sits on the front of it.
So we ship the Stackdriver
logs over to Pub/Sub.
From there, that got
pulled from Logstash
and then got ingested
into that ELK Stack.
Once we migrated over to GCP,
fast forward a few months,
we were able to remove
that Fluentd dummy boxes
and just ship straight into
Stackdriver Logging, so not
much change there.
So here, we kind of have
just the two logging systems.
We have the Stackdriver
Logging that people
were getting ramped up on
on how to use and leverage.
And then over on
the right, we had
Kibana, which is a bit
more friendly to new people
coming into logging.
So we'll go over that a
little bit in the demo.
So after you have
logging in place,
the next most critical thing
is monitoring, obviously,
so you need to know what
your systems are doing, where
the errors are coming in, when
you need to look at the logs
and dig in.
So we leveraged quite a
few open source products,
Prometheus being the big one,
and then Grafana for displaying
those Prometheus metrics.
And then, also with the
alerting, you need--
in the monitoring,
you need alerting.
So we had Node Advisor for
the system-level metrics.
That got shipped into
Prometheus. cAdvisor
for container-level metrics.
And then we had a
Blackbox exporter
that could actually kind of
work similar to a Pingdom
where it can just do a health
check to the application
to make sure that
they're still up.
On the front end
side, we didn't really
have to worry too much
about front end performance,
but we did still test it just
to make sure that we weren't
going to impact end users.
But we leveraged a
couple other open source
tools, one being sitespeed.io.
And then that integrated
with WebPageTest.
So we ran those side by
side comparing the front end
performance of our legacy
application and our GCP
application.
And then, last but not
least for the front end,
we also integrated with
Akamai mPulse, which
allowed us to get real user
monitoring from the end users'
browsers while we were
doing that migration,
so we could actually
lay them side by side
and we could see if
there was any performance
problems to our end users.
So with all that in
place, we decided
that we needed to get
more experience in GCP,
so we decided to do
table top exercises.
And within those
table top exercises,
we could do anything from
just stopping servers
to give people that operational
experience of debugging
and figuring out
what's going on.
Bad code deployments,
thundering herd problem.
How many people
have heard of that?
Any?
One, two.
So the thundering herd
problem is basically
just that you stop
all the traffic.
And then, all of a sudden, you
just send a bunch of traffic--
like exponential
amount of traffic.
So we tend to have live events,
things like CES and Black
Friday and things like that.
So we'll get a surge of traffic
if an iPhone gets released
or something like that.
So we wanted to
test that scenario.
So let's get into one of
the testing strategies
that we came up
internally, which
was the live replay
of production traffic.
So we brainstormed this
in-house after evaluating
with several external third
parties and open source
products.
They didn't quite fit
our needs internally.
We wanted to replicate live
traffic, not just simply replay
a percentage of a specific page
or types of page or anything
that's static like that.
So a lot of the
open source tools
allow you to replay things
like an article page
at 10%, reviews pages at 70%.
So it was very
static and you had
to pass at a static
list of URLs.
So going back to that
front end diagram,
we leveraged that
front end entry
point for our replay test.
And we realized that
all we had to do
to test the entire
system in the end
is really just send user traffic
like real users were coming in.
So let's walk through the
system that we built internally.
So obviously, you have
the end users there
on the right talking to our
legacy Phoenix data center
servers.
From there, we're
shipping those logs
using our syslog or logspout
over to Fluentd boxes in GCP.
From there, they get congested
in Stackdriver Logging.
From there, Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub can actually
kick off cloud functions.
And then within the
cloud functions,
we actually had the ability
to do any sort of programming
or manipulation of those
logs as they came in.
So we could introduce
errors, we could dynamically
just replay live traffic.
We could even time box
and replay certain logs
if we wanted to.
And then from there,
the cloud function
would actually issue those HTTP
calls over to the GCP boxes.
So this entire system allowed
us to dynamically replay
any sort of traffic coming
into Stackdriver Logging
and replay it to a
secondary system.
This is our just
normal CNET.com.
I pushed it up to CNETNext.
So what we want to do
is we want to leverage
that sweet retro CNET that
John mentioned earlier.
So what I did is I pulled
a retro.CNETNext.com.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to send traffic to
this one using those cloud
functions.
We're going to replay
that traffic over
to the retro system.
So jumping over to
the cloud console,
you can see I've already
pre-baked all the VMs.
We have the legacy
Swarm cluster that's
running that CNETNext.com.
Then we also have a
GKE cluster that's
running the retro.CNETNext.com.
And then, also, I have
a separate cluster
that's running tools, so
Grafana, the ELK Stack, things
like that.
So reconnect to that.
So here we got the
Kubernetes cluster.
It's got four nodes in
it, pretty standard stuff.
Jumping into one
of the workers, we
can actually look at the logs.
So going to hit Play on that.
So you can see I'm actually
leveraging another tool.
It's similar to Siege or Vegeta.
If anybody is
familiar with those,
what you can do
with those is you
can just send traffic
directly to a system,
and you can set a rate on that.
So we're sending
over traffic just
in case we don't
get enough hits.
So from there, we can
see those logs are coming
in to that legacy system.
And we can actually see a few
people actually coming in.
But you can see that
it's the actual Vegeta
system, because it has
the go HTTP client.
And then from there, we
can export out to Pub/Sub.
So we have a traffic
replay export
that's shipping over
to the Pub/Sub topics.
Just a note, if you
do have exports out
and you want to save
a little bit of money,
you can actually put in
exclusions on your logs
so that they don't actually
get stored into Stackdriver
Logging, but they will still
get shipped over to Pub/Sub.
So we do that to save
a little bit of money.
It's disabled right now.
So on the topic, we have--
the topic from the export,
from Stackdriver Logging,
it has two subscriptions
in it right now.
We jump over to that.
One is actually shipping
over to that cloud function,
and the other one is actually
getting pulled from an ELK
Stack that I'm actually running
in that tools Swarm cluster.
So if we take a look over
at those tools workers,
we actually have an ELK Stack
running in there pulling
those logs in real time.
I'm going to refresh
on here so you can see.
So we can see those logs
are coming in in real time.
And what that allows us
to do for the developers,
is this gives them an easy user
interface for them to get up
and running with
filtering logs, so
they get these nice
little buttons where
they can include and
exclude different filters
and track down any
sort of issues.
So jumping over to
the replay system,
so now we have a cloud
function that's actually
getting messages from the logs.
So you can see here we have that
cloud function actually running
right now.
It's issuing about 50 requests
a second over to the new system.
If we jump into
the source code--
going to dive a little
bit into the source code.
The source code is
pretty straightforward.
We're using Node 8 and
using request promises.
So with those requests
promises, we're
setting up the domain,
setting up the user agent.
We can actually set a
percentage inside the node code
and replay a certain percentage
of that traffic that's
coming into that legacy system.
So here we have it set to 10%.
And we're only replaying 10%
of the 100% traffic that's
coming into the legacy system.
So down here, we
set up the request.
We can put some
headers on there.
We actually changed
the user agent,
so we know it's coming from
the traffic replay system.
And then we can use the promises
and catch those promises,
whether it's successful
or if it fails.
So jumping over to the
logs, we can actually
watch the logs from the
cloud functions in real time.
And we can see when the
functions are executing
and how long they're taking
and that sort of thing.
Jumping back to the
Kubernetes cluster,
we can actually look
at the services.
We can see that CNET service
that's running the retro site.
We can look at those Stackdriver
logs from the new system.
And we can see the cloud
function is actually
coming in in real time.
So I'm going to jump
over here and I'm
going to change this
real quick from 10.
So I'm going to edit the
cloud function just so that we
can see this here in a second.
I'm going to change it to 100%.
Then I'm going to deploy that.
So while that's going, it's
going to change the replay
traffic over from 10% to 100%.
So we have our Prometheus
instances running.
That's capturing
all of our metrics.
We have Alertmanager that we
can actually fire off alerts
out to Slack or
anything like that.
I'm leveraging unsee,
which is basically
a wrapper for Alertmanager that
gives you a nice, pretty GUI.
So I actually have the tools--
cluster-- actually
showing a few [INAUDIBLE],,
so we could see what
that looks like.
And then Grafana.
So Grafana is the
big thing here.
We can actually look
at any of the metrics
across any of the legacy
clusters or Kubernetes cluster.
So here we're looking
at the Prometheus stats
from the tools Swarm
cluster, and we can make sure
that that's healthy.
We can look at the individual
Docker Node Swarm elements.
Let's switch over to the mic.
So oh-- OK.
We can look at the Swarm
node, the nodes themselves,
and we can actually see
the uptime of how long
those hosts are running
and any sort of system load
or performance that
was running on those.
Same thing for the
Swarm services.
We can see how many
replicas are running inside
of that Swarm cluster.
And then also, over on
the Kubernetes side,
we can look at Grafana
dashboards for the CNET site,
for that retro site, and
see how many containers are
running inside of Kubernetes.
Same thing-- with
Kubernetes or Swarm,
you can actually start
pulling in metrics
and start calculating cost and
build dashboards around that,
which is pretty neat.
And then finally, we can
mash all that up together
and we can create a replay
dashboard that actually shows
our Swarm cluster on the
left and our Kubernetes
cluster on the right, and we can
actually watch it in real time
as traffic is coming in.
So as we scroll in down here,
we can see on the Swarm,
we have the containers running.
We can look at the container
CPU, individual containers
in Swarm versus the individual
containers in Kubernetes.
Below that, we can look
at the actual host VM,
and look at the CPU usage
across the host VMs,
and then also the nodes
inside of Kubernetes.
In the middle, we
can see how many
requests are coming in per
minute from the legacy system
to the new system.
And then as we change
that cloud function,
we can see it react in real
time with those changes.
And then below that, we can see
requests per minute, per host.
So we're actually connecting
here over to the ELK Stack
that I'm running.
And we're actually pulling
the logs individually
from the ELK Stack
and then displaying
those on this dashboard.
And then below that,
finally, we can actually
connect to the
Stackdriver monitoring
and we can actually pull metrics
from those managed services
as well.
So here we're actually
looking at the Pub/Sub queue
of unacknowledged messages.
And we can see if we're
overloading the system
with too many messages.
And obviously, in this
demo, I am since I only
have one VM running.
Cool.
So that's basically it.
Can we jump back over
to the slides, I guess?
Cool.
So what's next?
I just wanted to call
out some of the tech
that we actually used on CNET.
The ones bolded here
are all the tech
we were able to use
for the CNET migration.
Obviously, there's
a lot more that we
can leverage with
the managed services
as we move off running
our own infrastructure
and move over to Kubernetes
and things like that.
And then here's a few
of the upcoming projects
that we're going to be
working on in 2019/2020.
Hopefully, leveraging GKE,
Memorystore, things like that,
so that we don't have
to run our own VMs.
And obviously, leveraging
that traffic replay system
that we just went through.
[MUSIC PLAYING]